to give you another example of how what
a strange and unique uh production this
was
myself as the co-editor on the
production i was
on the film 14 months before we started
shooting
and uh the reason for that was because
we had to put together
um
uh an edit initially we were kind of we
we were just flushing out ideas and we
were taking the storyboards and cutting
the storyboards together um
with some dialogue uh and just trying to
get a general idea of of how the the the
sequences and the scenes would go
together and that gradually grew into
something more and before we knew it we
were
taking these storyboarded
scenes
and giving them to the animators who
would then put together
a very rough previews
to try and tell
the story better than with the boards
and at this stage we had dialogue in
there i was playing george clooney's
character
and my assistant was playing uh sandra
bullock's character
and we were editing dialogue we were
moving dialogue around alfonso was
rewriting things and then
uh
we'd get animation back previous back
from
these guys and then we would manipulate
that and edit that
and
that would then go back to the animators
who at the head of we were we had to be
careful to keep up with each other
because we were all working at the same
time and if alfonzo wasn't with me then
he was with the previous guys and we did
this you know on all the sequences all
all together we were blocking the movie
in advance of the shoot and there were
two reasons for that there was one it
was
it was necessary to start telling the
story and to know the the shape of the
film and how the film would be
would ultimately come together in a much
more
cohesive way
than
most other films
would would ever do any sort of previews
before shooting and the second reason
was because
the shots were so complex
everybody in pre-production
needed to know use the cut as their
basis
for uh calculating the logistics behind
the shoot
yeah initially there was um just a
handful of people and it was you know
but but
because the sequences were so long the
team grew eventually i think we had over
20 animators working on the previous we
previous the whole film
um
so we were sharing sharing sequences and
we realized that
because alfonso was really pushing
not necessarily the details of the
animation but i mean he's obsessive with
composition and timings of the camera
and all the nuances of that were really
pushed in the previous were you
surprised at how
beautifully they wove together these
discreetly precise stagings into one
continuous flowing piece well it it it
had it was gradually worked up actually
you know and and that was one of the
reasons why as the movie we went on
we did less and less storyboarding i
think we storyboarded the whole movie
but we we relied more and more on
previews and the previews in many ways
was the spine of the movie from the
beginning to the end but um you know
however useful the storyboards are as an
initial starting point and they are
because so much of it is about movement
and timing and and all the things we've
been talking about we we
moved into previews uh you know sooner
as we as we went down the process and
also we found we had to previous to a
higher level of detail because so many
things were relying on the previous so
the previous had to be
you know worked up to
much more accurate animation than
previous normally is
because of the way we shot it
we were able to explore the
dimensionality
of
zero gravity in a way that you couldn't
in a normal traditional shooting because
you know normally in a film people are
standing on the ground so this makes
everything kind of two-dimensional
people can move left and right but it's
you know often to move up and down so
the compositions
are very kind of locked within that you
know we're used to seeing people framed
in a certain way
and you know one of the big briefs
is that the compositions should break
with that
um traditional structure i mean i
remember when we were doing the previous
everybody was you know we were having
fun
doing all this stuff and everybody was
saying well you know actually we've got
to film that and that was almost like an
inconvenience you know
we sort of tried to not think about it
and give alfonso just say look just
let's just go and make it have fun
try and you know come up with some cool
sequences and then leave it up to tim to
work out how we were going to shoot it i
have to say tim was very very gracious
because also editorially we were
manipulating all these previews and i
was spinning things around and flopping
the shot and moving stuff around and
re-timing things with the purposes of
the edit and i knew that every time i
did it tim would be receiving this edit
a few minutes later and banging his head
against the brick wall because of what i
just done